- [Instructor] Ah, the
basic building blocks
of all living things, cells.
These incredible packages of organelles
and subcellular components
carry out a variety of
functions in the body,
like taking in nutrients,
converting them into energy,
and working with other
cells to produce things
that the body needs.
Each cell is essentially like
its own little mini factory,
with complex processes
occurring within the cell
to carry out specific functions.
Okay, so when we zoom into
the cell to figure out
how exactly these cell
processes are carried out,
one of the star players
is a class of biological
macromolecules known as proteins.
Proteins carry out
many incredibly important
tasks in the cell,
such as providing structural support,
aiding in chemical reactions
and even building or repairing the cell.
We can imagine proteins
as a chain of amino acids,
kind of think of them as
like beads on a bracelet
that fold and twist into distinct
three-dimensional shapes.
The structure of a protein
along with the chemical
properties of its amino acid,
evidently, determine its function.
Does it form a round, globular sphere
that can attach and interact
with other compounds?
Or does it twist into
long and narrow strands
that can provide structural support?
The huge variety of structures
that proteins can take on
leads to the wide range
of cellular functions
that they can carry out.
Okay, so now that we've
talked about proteins,
let's zoom back out
to analyze how different
types of cells come together
to carry out a variety of
functions in an organism.
This is where cell
specialization comes into play,
which is the process by
which a cell takes on
a specific structure and function.
So to better help understand this concept,
let's consider a movie theater analogy
where the movie theater is your body.
There is the cashier that
handles all the money,
the snack vendor who handles
out popcorn and snacks
and even the ticket operator
who directs you to the proper screenings.
In this analogy,
each person has their
own distinct functions
in what they handle,
like money or popcorn or tickets.
In a similar way,
the body is also composed
of specialized cells
with unique roles,
such as red blood cells that
carry oxygen in the blood,
muscle cells that contract and relax
or even nerve cells that
carry signaling messages
throughout the body.
Now, remember how I told
you about proteins before?
Well, cell specialization is largely based
on which proteins are present
or absent in the cell.
It is a cell's unique
combination of proteins
that determine which
functions can be carried out.
But no cell works alone,
because teamwork makes the dream work.
Groups of specialized cells
that carry out specific
functions for the organism
are organized into tissues.
Looking back at our movie theater analogy,
there are multiple people
within each department
that work together to help the
theater function efficiently.
Similarly, our specialized
cells work together
as tissues to help the organism function.
The red blood cells make up the blood,
a connective tissue
that moves important
substances throughout the body.
The muscle cells help
make up muscle tissue
which helps the body move
and neurons or nerve cells
make up nervous tissue
that helps the organism
process information.
So what are the key takeaways
about cell specialization?
Number one, cells are the
fundamental unit of life.
They're the smallest structural
and functional unit of an organism.
Number two, proteins help
carry out cell processes.
Number three, specialized cells carry out
specific functions in an organism.
Think of the movie theater analogy
where each person has
its own specific role.
And number four, groups
of specialized cells
come together as tissues
to carry out one or
more specific functions
for the organism.